the FBI is seeking more information on
James Hodgkinson and his motive agents
searched his Belleville Illinois home
for evidence yesterday authorities
believe that Hodgkinson had not lived
there since March when he arrived in
Virginia Dean Reynolds is outside his
house in Belleville about 700 miles from
where he opened fire in the Alexandria
baseball field Dean good morning to you
good morning well those who knew the man
who lived in this house behind me say he
was unhappy with the political direction
of the country but they never expected
him to turn violent known to many as Tom
James Hodgkinson grew up in Belleville
graduating from a local high school in
1968 he lived in this house with his
wife and ran a home inspection business
until his license expired last November
I'm very surprised ray Paige knew him
for 30 years I've never seen the man
violent since I've ever since I've known
him deeply engaged in politics
Hodgkinson did not keep his views secret
99% of getting pushed around and and the
1% are just not giving a damn in a 2015
Facebook post Hodgkinson shared a
political cartoon about yesterday's
victim Congressman Steve Scalise saying
here's a Republican that should lose his
job but they gave him a raise in recent
months he began showing disdain for the
current administration in a March 22nd
post he wrote it's time to destroy Trump
and company just two days later a
neighbor complained after hearing 50
shots fired from Hodgkinson property he
was very nice said hey I'll take it to a
race somewhere that's safer and that was
the end of it his Republican Congressman
Mike boss said that Hodgkinson contacted
his office at least 10 times by phone
and email when we look those over there
is never a one that crosses a line he's
not happy with my position he would
prefer that I voted this way if I don't
vote this way they'll work against me
next time you know but no threat beyond
that
now Hodgkinson did have an arrest record
dating back to the 1970s but they were
mostly minor offenses that were later
dismissed Gayle Dean thank you very much